digamos que queremos calcular a que es
igual un medio menos un tercio y podemos
visualizar cada una de estas fracciones
un medio se ve así en donde tomamos un
entero y lo dividimos en dos partes
iguales una de esas dos secciones
iguales será un medio y no vemos
sombreado en verde aquí y a partir de
esto vamos a tratar de restar un tercio
podemos visualizar así todo esto es un
entero y lo dividimos en tres secciones
iguales y una de esas tres secciones
iguales es un tercio lo que vamos a
hacer es quitarle esta caja gris a esta
caja verde y calcular cómo podemos
encontrar matemáticamente lo que queda
así que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta les daré una
pista va a ser útil representar los
medios y los tercios en términos de un
denominador diferente muy bien vamos a
resolver estos juntos la forma en la que
vamos a hacerlo es encontrando un
denominador común si podemos expresar
ambas fracciones en términos del mismo
denominador va a ser mucho más fácil la
resta y lo más útil es encontrar el
mínimo común denominador y el menor
número que es múltiplo de 2 y de 3 es 2
por 3 o 6 como vamos a escribir cada uno
de estos números en términos de sextos
como podemos reescribir un medio en
términos de sextos bueno si comenzamos
con un medio y multiplicamos el
denominador por 3 esto nos va a dar
sextos pero no queremos cambiar el valor
de la fracción por lo que necesitamos
multiplicar el numerador por 3 también
siempre que multipliquemos tanto el
numerador como el denominador por la
misma cantidad
la fracción seguirá siendo igual en este
caso un medio y podemos visualizar cómo
luce esto si tomamos cada una de estas
dos secciones iguales y las dividimos en
tres secciones iguales entonces vamos a
tener un total de seis secciones o
sextos dos por tres en el denominador y
la parte sombreada en verde que era una
de esas secciones
ahora tiene tres secciones así que un
medio es ahora igual a 13 entre 6 y
podemos hacer lo mismo por aquí si
comenzamos con un tercio como lo
expresamos en términos de sextos para
pasar de 3 a 6
necesitamos multiplicarlo por 2 y
también queremos hacerlo en el numerador
para no cambiar el valor de la fracción
y podemos visualizar esto noten que si
tomamos estas tres secciones y dividimos
entre 2 cada una
vamos a tener seis secciones iguales
ahora ya tenemos sextos y una de esas
secciones se volverá dos secciones así
que ahora va a ser igual a dos sextos
por lo que ahora podemos reescribir
estas cosas como tres sextos menos dos
sextos para que creen que va a ser igual
esto bueno si tenemos tres de algo y le
restamos dos de ese algo vamos a
quedarnos con uno de ese algo nos vamos
a quedar con un sexto en este caso y
podemos visualizar esto como hemos
visualizado todo lo demás
dos de estas barras grises o dos de
estas tres secciones nos vamos a quedar
con una de ellas esta es una de esas
seis secciones iguales